[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: All right,
why don't we get started?
It's 2:35, time to begin.
So everyone, welcome back--
good to see you all.
Well, at least a few of you--
glad that you're here.
So let's see.
Why don't I get a layout, as I
usually do, where we have been,
where we're going today.
I'll talk a little tiny
bit about the homework,
because I've gotten a
couple of questions on that.
And then we'll jump in.
So we have been talking
about Turing machines, which
is going to be our
preferred model for the rest
of the semester, since Turing
machines are the model which
we use to capture general
purpose computing.
And we looked at Turing
machines in various variations
on Turing machines--
multi-tapes, non-deterministic,
and so on.
It's a bit recapping the history
of the subject, when people
looked at a variety of
different ways of formalizing
the notion of algorithm.
And they showed that all of
those different formalizations
were equivalent to one another,
which led to the Church-Turing
thesis that all
of these models--
each of these models really
capture our intuitive idea
of what we mean by a procedure
or an algorithm for--
at least for addressing things
like mathematical problems
and precise problems
of that kind.
So we talked about the
Church-Turing thesis.
We also talked about a notation
for encodings and Turing
machines.
We'll review that briefly.
So today we're going to give
a bunch of examples of Turing
machine algorithms for solving
a variety of different problems.
I should just say
algorithms really--
nothing special about
Turing machines.
Turing machines are just going
to be our formal counterpart.
But from now on, we're going
to use our Church-Turing thesis
in a way to just talk about
algorithms in general,
because that's
really our interest.
Turing machines is just our
way of reasoning about them
mathematically, but
we're really ultimately
interested in
understanding algorithms.
In terms of the format
of today's class,
I'm going to try a
little experiment.
We're going to have little
breaks along the way,
as well as the big coffee
break in the middle.
We're going to have a little
mini breaks, because I
sometimes feel that there really
isn't enough time for people
to be writing chat--
questions in the chat, because
things just are racing on.
And so this way we'll have
a little break after the--
pretty much after each slide.
Some of them are going to be
a little longer than others.
In case you have questions,
you can pose them
to me or to the TAs, and
we'll try to get back to you
on those.
So moving on then, so today,
just as a quick review,
Turing machines, as we
set them up, they have--
on any input w, they have
three possible outcomes.
The Turing machine
can halt and accept w,
can halt and reject w,
or it can go forever
on w, which is rejecting
by looping in our language.
A Turing machine can recognize
a language, the collection
of old strings that it accepts.
And if the Turing
machine always halts,
we say it decides the
language, and it's a decider,
and so therefore, that language
is a decided language, a Turing
decider.
Often we just say decidable,
because we don't really
have a notion of
deciding in other models,
so we often talk about
Turing-recognizable
or just decidable.
Or we'll sometimes
just say recognizable,
when we understand that we're
talking about Turing machines.
We briefly talked
about encodings.
When you write it inside
brackets, some objects--
whatever they are-- could be
strings, could be machines,
could be graphs,
could be polynomials--
we're representing
them as strings,
and maybe a
collection of objects
together represented
as a string in order
so that we can present
that information
as an input to a machine.
And we talk about--
our languages our
collections of strings.
And a notation for
writing a Turing machine
is going to be simply that
English description put
inside quotation
marks to represent
our informal way of talking
about the formal object
that we could produce,
if we wanted to.
But we're never going
to ask you to do that.
OK, so now let me see.
Let's just take a quick
break, as I promised.
If there's any quick
questions here, you can ask.
Let's see-- got a lot
of questions here.
All right, why don't we move on?
And some of these things
are good questions.
Somebody asked, can
you-- how do you
tell if the machine is looping
or if it's really just taking
a very long time?
You can't.
That's what we're going to
prove not in today's lecture,
but going to prove
that on Thursday.
You just can't tell.
So if that's in
reference to problem 5,
you're going to have to find
some other way of doing--
solving that problem without
knowing whether the machine is
actually ever going to halt.
And somebody asked,
how can we tell
if an English description is
possible for a Turing machine?
Well, you can always write
down an English description
for any machine.
It's-- might be very
technical looking,
but if you can write it down
in a formal way as states
and transitions, then you can
simply write down an English
description, which would
just be, follow those states.
OK, let's move on.
OK, this is going to
be our first example
of a algorithm that's
going to answer
a question about automata.
And it's a very simple problem.
It's a very simple
problem to solve,
because we want
to start out easy.
The name of the problem
is the acceptance problem
for deterministic
finite automata,
acceptance problem for DFAs.
And I'm going to express it,
as I always do, as a language.
So with this language here,
I'm calling it a ADFA--
which stands for the
acceptance problem for DFAs--
is the collection of pairs.
B and w--
B is a DFA.
w is considered to be
some other string, which
will be an input to B.
We're going to be thinking
of it as an input to B.
I put the two of them
in brackets to represent
the pair of them
as a single string.
We're not going to make explicit
what the form of the encoding
is.
The only important thing
is that the encoding should
be something simple, but
that the Turing machine
can decode back into the DFA and
this input string to that DFA.
So anything reasonable is going
to be a satisfactory encoding
from us-- for us.
So this is an encoding of the
two of them into a string,
and where B is a
DFA, and B accepts w.
So now, if you want to test if
something's a member of ADFA,
then, first of all,
you want to make sure
that the string itself
that you're getting really
encodes a DFA and a string.
So it has to be the right form.
And once you know that,
then you have the DFA,
you have the string
w, and you're then
going to do the
obvious thing, which
would be to simulate
B on w and see
if it's actually accepting w.
So that's what the
content of this slide is.
I'm just going to
write it down for you.
So I'm going to give a
Turing machine, which
I'm going to call--
the name of that Turing
machine is going to be D A DFA.
To help you remember the
function of this machine.
This is a decider
for the language
below, the ADFA language.
This is just a name, but-- so
nothing fancy going on here,
but just to help us
remember, because I'm
going to refer to some of
these Turing machines later on.
So this is the decider for ADFA.
And I'm going to describe
that machine for you,
and that machine decides
the ADFA language.
So what does that mean?
So that machine--
I'm describing it now in
English, as I promised.
We're going to take
an input string s,
and first, it's going to check
that s has the right form, as I
mentioned-- has
the form which is
the encoding of a DFA and a w.
If it's not of that
form, the Turing machine
should reject that
input right away.
Now, I'm not going to go through
the details of how that Turing
machine is going to work, though
I'll say a little bit more
this time only just to give
you a sense of how it actually
might carry that out.
If you don't believe that
you can do it with a Turing
machine, believe you could do it
with your favorite programming
language.
That's good enough,
because that's
going to be-- that's
equivalent to a Turing machine.
So first, you check that the
input's of the right form.
Then you're going to simulate
the computation of B on w.
And then, if B ends
up in an accept state,
then we know B is accepting the
input, and we should accept,
and we do.
If B does not end up in an
accept state at the end of w,
then we should reject,
because B is not accepting w.
OK?
That's my description
of this machine.
Let's just turn to a
little bit of details
just to make sure we're
comfortable with this.
So here is our Turing machine--
D, the decider for ADFA.
The input to that Turing
machine, as I mentioned,
is going to be B and w,
provided it's of the right form.
So that's what this string S
is supposed to be of that form.
And what does that mean?
It's just an encoding of the
machine w and the string--
the machine B and the string w.
Let me just write it down.
Here is B written down in some
just completely explicit way,
where you're just listing the
states of B, the alphabet of B,
the transition function as
a table, the start state,
and the set of
accepting states--
just writing it down
explicitly, as you might do it
if you would just
want to describe
that machine in a
completely formal way,
and then writing down
with the string is--
whatever it is.
Once DADFA has
that as its input,
it can then go ahead
and do that computation.
And just to try to make it
a little bit more explicit,
I'm going to capture
that here by saying,
let's give that Turing
machine an extra tape,
because we already know that the
multi-tape model is equivalent
to the single tape model--
make our life perhaps
a little easier.
And in the course of doing
that simulation, what
do we want to keep track of?
Well, what is the current
state of B, the DFA,
as we're reading
the symbols of w?
And where in w are
we at right now?
So I'll call that k, which is
the input head location on w.
How many symbols
of w have we read?
OK?
And that's all I'm going to say
about what this Turing machine
D looks like.
Oh, there's one more thing
I do want to say for the--
that's coming up, because pretty
much all of the Turing machines
that we're going to talk
about today and going forward
are going to often want to
check that their input is
of the correct form.
I don't want to repeat this
every time, because that's
going to be assumed.
So my shorthand for that is
to say my input is of the form
I'm looking for, and
that has built into it
the check that the string--
the input string
is of that form,
and we're going to
reject if it is not.
So all of our
Turing machines are
going to start out, on
input, the string is
of a certain form, and then go
out and do something with it.
OK?
OK, so let me try to answer
a few of the questions
that I've gotten here, because
I think this is important
as a way of getting
us all started.
Now, somebody asked me, can
we use arguments of this form?
Somebody asking, can we use--
can we give our
description of a procedure,
if I'm understanding
this correctly,
as using some other
programming language?
Well, typically, you just want
to make sure you're understood.
If you want to do
that on a homework,
I wouldn't advocate writing
your algorithm in Java,
because it's going
to be hard to read.
But write it down in some
pseudo programming language
if you want, just to
make sure it's clear
that-- what you're doing.
Probably English is going
to be the easiest for you--
even though this person says--
feels it would be
easier to do it
in terms of a formal language.
Well, whatever's easier-- as
long as we can understand it.
This is a good question
here I got to ask.
What if B-- here's our
B-- gets into a loop on w?
Well, that's not
going to happen.
B is a DFA.
DFAs-- they move from state
to state every time they
read a symbol of w.
When they get to the end of
w, it's the end of the story.
There's no more
computation to be done.
So we know in exactly
how many steps
B is ever going to
take on-- it's going
to take the same number of steps
as the length of the input.
That's how many moves
it gets to make.
B as a DFA never loops.
So that would be a problem if
it did loop, but it doesn't.
That input never does loop.
So have we verified
that D is a decider?
Well, I think I just did.
From my standpoint, we've
said enough to be sure
that D is a decider.
There's never any
reason for D to be--
for that DADFA Turing machine
to be getting into a loop.
The input head location
is referring to where
we are on the string w?
Yes.
And somebody's asking
me, is this the level
of detail for the homework?
Yes.
That's all I want.
It's all I'm looking for.
OK?
Let us move on.
I'm going to have to--
otherwise we'll
never get anywhere.
There are a lot
of questions here.
They're good questions.
So why don't we go on?
Some of these may
get resolved as we're
going to look at
additional examples,
because that's all of today
is pretty much examples.
Let's talk about the similar
problem, the acceptance
problem, but now for NFAs.
So now, actually,
NFAs can loop, so we
have to think about what
that possibly could look at.
But before we get ahead
of ourselves-- so now
the acceptance problems for
NFAs looked very similar,
except B is going to be an NFA.
That's going to be a
decidable language too.
And now we have
Turing machine A--
DANFA, the decider for
ANFA that decides ANFA.
OK?
So now, as promised,
here's our new form
for writing our Turing machine.
On input B, w, we're
assuming that B--
based on the context,
sometimes you
may want to say at this
point, what B and w are.
But from the context,
we know what they are.
They're going to be an NFA
and an input w for that NFA.
I do want to jump
into the solution.
First, before we actually look
at the solution of this, we--
the Turing machine could
simulate the NFA on input w.
And you have to be
careful on that simulation
that you don't end up
looping, because don't forget,
an NFA could have epsilon
moves, and could be
looping on those epsilon moves.
And so that would be a problem,
if you're not careful about how
you do that simulation.
Now, I think, if you were
going to simulate an NFA,
you would be--
wouldn't follow loop
around loops forever.
And I think you can--
without getting--
because this is not
the way I'm going to
solve the problem--
you could find a way
to avoid getting caught
and getting stuck
in loops for an NFA.
So even though that looks like
it could be a problem, in terms
of looping forever, it turns
out that it won't be a problem--
it wouldn't be a problem
if you're careful.
But I'm not going
to solve it that way
anyway, because I'm going to
illustrate a different method
for solving this problem.
And that is we have exhibited
before a way of converting NFAs
to DFAs.
So my Turing machine is going
to solve the ANFA problem
by converting its
input, which is an NFA,
to an equivalent DFA.
I'm calling the
NFA B and the DFA
that I got-- converting
it into B prime.
And what's nice about that
is that, first of all,
we already know how to do
that conversion, because we
essentially went over that in
lecture a few lectures back,
and it's spelled out in
full detail in the textbook.
So that is a conversion
we know how to do--
we'll assume we know how to do.
And we can implement that
Turing-- that conversion
on a Turing machine.
Then, once we have
the equivalent DFA,
what do we do with that?
In the previous
slide, we showed how
to solve the problem for DFAs.
So if we can convert
the NFA to a DFA,
and then we already know how
to solve the problem for DFAs,
then we're done.
So that's how I'm going to say.
We're going to convert
the NFA to a DFA,
and then I'm going
to run that DADFA
problem on the new
machine that I produced.
So remember that the--
this machine here
decides the ADFA problem.
And now I'm going to accept,
if that new machine--
if that previous Turing machine
accepts the DADFA problem
the machine accepts, and
I'm going to basically do
whatever it does.
If it accepts, I'll accept.
If it rejects, then I'll reject.
So I guess the thing
that this illustrates
is this idea of using a
conversion construction
inside a Turing
machine, and then
a previously constructed
Turing machine
basically as a subroutine.
All this is perfectly legal,
and it's the kind of thing
we're going to be
doing a lot of,
and that you should
be used to doing
that-- get ready to be doing
that on your homework too.
And in fact, I'll give you
another a little extra hint
that problem 6 can be
solved in this way.
OK.
All right, so here,
let's pause briefly.
OK, got some interesting
questions here coming up--
somebody asked me,
do we need to be
explicit about how
we're going to simulate
that NFA or the DFA?
Because we don't know
how many states it has.
You do know how
many states it has.
Once it's presented
to you on the input,
you can see, oh, this is a
machine that has 12 states--
because you're given
the machine, and then
you can do the simulation.
Let's see.
And someone's asking me about
limits on the simulation
power of a Turing machine.
That's a question that I'm
going to postpone to later,
because you're
asking if a Turing
machine can simulate itself.
And we'll talk about
things like that,
but that's in a
few weeks from now,
so I'll hold off on that one.
Decidable languages--
somebody's asking me
a good question about closure
properties of the class
of decidable languages.
Are they closed under
intersection, union, and so on?
Yes.
And the decidable languages are
also closed under complement.
That should be something
you should think about.
But yes, that is true.
The recognizable
languages, however,
are closed under union
and intersection,
but they are not closed
under complement.
So that we will prove
on Thursday's lecture.
So another question is, could we
have just run B on w in this--
in solving this problem,
instead of using reduced--
converting it to a
new Turing machine--
the B prime?
Well, yes, we could
have just done that.
OK.
I think we better move on.
I don't want to get
too bogged down here--
got a lot of questions
there, so sorry
if I'm not getting to
all of the questions.
OK.
Or you can write to
the TAs too, obviously.
I'm sure you are.
OK, so let's talk about
a different problem--
emptiness problem for DFAs.
I'm going to give you now a--
just a DFA--
B-- and no input.
And I'm going to ask, is
the language of that DFA
the empty set, the
empty language?
You understand the
problem, first of all?
I'm just handing you in a
DFA, and I want to know,
does this DFA accept
any strings at all,
or is it just some dumb DFA--
it's just always
very negative DFA,
it just rejects everything--
and it has the empty language?
How do you tell?
Not super hard, if
you think about how
you would write a
program to do that
or how you would
do it yourself--
so that's a decidable
language again.
So we're going to give
now a Turing machine
decider for that language.
That decider says, well,
I'm giving that DFA--
I want to know if its
language is empty.
And the idea is just
what you would think.
I'm going to see, is there
a path from the start state
of that DFA to the-- an
accept state of the DFA?
If there is such a
path, then that DFA
is going to have an input
which goes along that path,
and will be accepted.
And so the language
won't be empty.
If there's no such path,
then clearly, this DFA
can never accept anything, and
so this language will be empty.
OK.
Now, there are many
different path algorithms.
I think it would be a little
bit sparse of me just--
some of you know algorithms.
Some of you don't know
path checking algorithms.
I would like you to just
to-- if you were giving
this kind of an
answer on a homework,
to give me some sense
of how that algorithm is
going to work.
Don't be too high
level about it.
So the one I have in mind
is the breadth research,
if you've heard of that.
But it's very simple algorithm.
What I'm going to use is
kind of a marking procedure.
So I'm going to start
by coloring the--
here is this-- I should have
indicated-- this is my DFAB.
This is B over here.
Should I try taking a chance
of writing on this thing--
oops.
This is B. Oh, great--
that didn't help.
So this is B here.
And the way I'm going to
test if it has a path--
if it accepts an
input is by seeing
if there's a path from
the start state to any one
of the accept states.
And I'm going to start it
by marking the start state,
and then marking
all states that I
can get to from
previously marked states,
and keep doing that until I
can't get to anything new.
There's going to be a series
of iterations here marking
more and more states until
there's nothing new to mark,
and then I say, did I
mark any accept states?
OK, so let's just see how I
write that down in English.
So I started marking
the start state.
I repeat until no
new state is marked.
I'm going to say,
mark every state that
has an incoming arrow from
a previously marked state.
Accept-- then, once I'm done
with, that repeat loop--
accept if no accept state is
marked, because that means--
don't forget, it's a
little bit inverted
from what you might think.
I'm going to accept if there's
no marked accept state,
because that means there's
no path to an accept state
from the start state, which
means the language is empty.
And EDFA is the DFAs
that have empty language,
so I should be accepting those.
If there's no way to
get to an accept state,
no accept state is marked.
And reject if some accept
state earmark, because then
the language is not empty.
OK, so that's all I
wanted to say about that.
Somebody's asking,
can you just say
something like breadth
versus [AUDIO OUT]..
The sketchier you
are, the more chances
that you're going to get
caught by the grader, who's
not going--
we have an army of people
grading these problems,
and just to stay on the--
be on the safe
side of sketchiness
and, say, don't cut
too many corners,
because you might
miss something.
Chances are it would be OK
just to say breadth research,
but I would prefer if--
you'd be safer if you said
a little bit more than that.
OK.
Oh, this is a good
question here.
Somebody asked, can we just
run the DFA on all short--
on all strings?
Well, first of all, one thing--
to say something bad
would be, well, just
feed in all possible
strings into the DFA,
and if any one of them--
if it accepts any
one of them, then we
know its language is not empty.
Well, that's not
a good algorithm,
because that's going to
potentially run forever,
because there's lots of strings.
There's infinitely many
strings to feed in to that DFA.
And so a Turing machine, if
it's trying to be a decider,
had better not do any infinite
operations that are potentially
going to go forever.
To be fair to the proposer
here, the questioner here--
didn't ask that-- says, well,
can we feed in all strings
up to some bound, which
would be the number of states
of the machine in this case?
And yes, that would
work, but then you
would have to argue
that that's enough.
And yes, it is enough, but it
wouldn't-- would not be enough
in answering the
problem just to say,
feed it in that number
of them, and we're done.
You would have to say why.
OK.
Lot of questions here--
I'm going to move on.
Let's see.
Equivalence problem for DFAs--
now we're going to take things
to the next level-- ask,
are there two--
I'm going to give you two DFAs.
And I want to know, do they
describe the same language--
do they recognize
the same language?
OK?
So how are we going to do that?
So that's a decidable language.
Here's the decider.
My input now is going
to be two DFAs--
again, represented as a
string, because that's
what Turing machines deal
with as their inputs.
But they can unpack that
string into two DFAs.
And there are several different
ways to do this problem,
and I'm sure I'm going to get
suggestions with other ways
to go.
One thing you could do is
just to feed in strings
up to a certain length.
Just like before, you can't
feed in all possible strings
and see if the machines
ever behave differently
on any of them, because
that's an infinite operation,
and we already decided
we can't do that.
Now, if you want
to talk about this
being a recognizer,
instead of a decider,
then you might be able
to do something like that
just to make sure your--
you have to be just careful.
Let me not say more
on that right now.
But certainly, for a decider,
you can't go forever.
You can't have
infinite operations.
So you would have
to have a cut-off.
So you can feed in all possible
strings up to some length,
say, into A and B, and see
if there's any difference.
Now, we actually had a problem
on that in the problem set
1, which said, if two DFAs
have unequal languages,
then they're going
to see a difference.
Then there's going to be a
string which acts differently
on them, which is
of length, at most,
the product of the number of
states of those two machines.
So you can either
reference that problem--
that would be an adequate
solution-- or reprove it
or whatever.
That would be fine.
In fact, you can do
even better than that,
as the optional problem showed.
You only have to go up to the
sum of the number of states,
not up to the product.
But that's actually
very difficult to show.
I'm not going to
prove it that way.
I'm going to prove it in an
entirely different way, which
doesn't require any
analysis at all--
no proving something
about balance.
I'm going to take advantage of
something we've already shown,
which is I'm going to make
a new finite automaton,
a new DFAC built out
of A and B, which
accepts all the strings
on which A and B disagree.
And I'll show you how to--
that's easy to do.
So first of all, let's--
in terms of a picture,
let's understand what this is.
So here we have--
this is the language of
A, this is the language
of B written as a Venn diagram.
And where are those places
where they disagree?
Well, they're either in
A, but not in B, or in B,
but not in A. I'm
showing it to you here
in terms of the blue region.
That actually has a name
called the symmetric difference
of these two sets.
These are the--
all of the members
which are in exactly one out
of the two, but not both.
If you can make a machine C that
would accept all of the strings
in the blue region, then what
do we do with that machine?
We test of its length
language is empty,
which is what we've
already shown how to do--
because of the blue region is
empty, that means that L of A
equals L of B.
So I'm going to make a machine,
a DFAC where the language of C
is exactly that
symmetric difference.
It's all the strings in A
intersected with the strings
that are not in B-- so in A and
not in B-- or in B and not--
then not an A--
take the union of
those two parts.
And how do we know
we can make C?
Well, we have those
closure constructions,
which we showed
several lectures back.
Those closure instructions
can be implemented
on a Turing machine.
So a Turing machine
can build the DFAC,
and then use that test
from a few slides back,
the emptiness-- the last
slide-- the emptiness tester
for DFAs on C to see whether
its language is empty.
And now, if C's
language is empty,
then we know we can
accept, because that
means the two-- that L of
A equals L of B. Otherwise,
we can reject.
OK?
So here's a note--
I'm going to ask you a check-in.
You can also use that time to
send me a few more questions,
if you want.
OK, here's my check-in.
OK, now, instead of testing
equivalence of finite--
of DFAs, I want to
test equivalence
of regular expressions.
So here are R1, R2.
Regular expressions are called
the EQ regular expressions
problem--
equivalents of
regular expressions.
Can we now conclude that this
problem is also decidable,
either immediately from
stuff we've already shown;
or yes, but would take some
significant extra work; or no,
because intersection is
not a regular operation?
So let's see if I can pull that
out here-- launch the polling.
Here we go.
OK, I think we're
just about done here.
Five seconds more--
OK, ready, set, end.
All right.
Yes, the correct answer is A.
We have basically already shown
this fact, because--
why is that?
Because we have shown
that we can convert--
if you're given two
regular expressions,
and we want to test
whether they're equivalent,
they generate the
same language, we
can convert them both
to find out automata.
We can convert them to NFAs,
and then the NFAs to DFAs.
And then we can
apply what we've just
showed about testing
equivalence of DFAs.
So yes, it really follows
immediately from stuff
we've already shown-- the
conversion, number one,
and then the testing of
equivalence for DFAs.
So there's not really
any work to do here.
And in fact, what I'm trying to
illustrate with this check-in--
that, once you've shown
how to do some kind
of a test for one model, it--
going to apply for all
of the equivalent models
that we've shown to be
equivalent, because the Turing
machine can do the constructions
which show the equivalence.
OK, so let's move on.
Somebody didn't get the poll.
Did most people
not get the poll?
Well, I think most of
you have gotten it.
Did you?
I'm not seeing a
lot of complaints.
So if you didn't get
the poll, something
is wrong with your
setup, and you're
going to have to take the
recorded check-ins that
are going to launch right
after this lecture's over.
Sorry.
But you should figure out
what's wrong with the setup
there, because I think most
people are getting these.
OK, and with that, we're
going to take a little break,
and then we'll
continue on afterward.
Let me know how this is--
should I be speed
a little speedier
about the little mini
breaks that we're taking,
or is this good for you?
Feedback is always--
I'm trying to make this as
good as I can for all of you.
OK, I think there's a mixture
of between people saying
that these breaks are good.
Someone says they're
a little overlong,
so I'll try to tighten
them up a little.
Some folks are saying what--
more people should
be asking the TAs.
I don't know how the TAs are
doing, in terms of their--
I'll check with them
afterward-- how well
this is going for them,
in terms of the questions.
But I think some amount of
break is good so that we don't--
so there's time to
be asking questions.
Otherwise, what's the point
of having a live lecture?
So we will start promptly
when this timer runs down.
So be ready to go in
55 seconds from now.
Just to confirm, to show the
decidability of the equivalence
of two regular
expressions, do we
need to show that we can use a
Turing machine to convert them
to two DFAs first?
If you want to test whether
two regular expressions are
equivalent, you can
give any procedure
for doing that
deciding you want.
I'm just offering one
simple way to do it
that takes advantage of
stuff we've already shown.
But if you want
to dig down and do
some analysis of those
regular expressions
to show that they describe
the same language,
they generate the same
language, be my guest.
I think that's-- actually would
be complicated to do that that
way.
OK, so we're just about ready
to go here, so let's continue.
And let me take
this timer off here.
All right.
Now, we are going
to talk a little
about context-free grammars.
So we talked about decision
problems for finite automata.
Let's talk about
some for grammars.
OK, now I'm going to give
us an analogous problem.
I'm going to give you a--
I'm calling it the
acceptance problem,
but-- just for consistency
with everything else,
but it's really the
generating problem.
So I'm giving you a grammar--
context-free grammar G and
a string that's in a string.
And I want to know, is
it in the language of G?
So does G generate w?
I'm calling that
the ACFG problem.
So that's going to
be a decidable again.
These are getting slightly
harder as we're moving along,
so I'm giving you a grammar and
a string, and I want to know,
does the grammar
generate that string?
Well, it's not totally
trivial to solve that.
One thing you might try doing is
looking at all possible things,
all possible derivations
from that grammar
and see if any one
of them leads to w--
leads you to generate w.
Well, you have to be careful,
because as I've-- as we've
shown in some of our examples,
you actually could have--
because you're allowed
to have variables
that can get converted
to empty string,
you might have very long
intermediate strings being
generated from a, grammar
which then ultimately give you
a small string of terminals
that get generated,
a small string in the
language that gets produced.
You certainly don't want to
try every possible derivation,
because there's infinitely
many different derivations--
most of them
generating, of course,
things that are irrelevant
to the string w.
But you have to know
how to cut things off,
and it's not immediately
obvious how you do that--
unless you have done the
homework problems that I asked
you to do, which I'm sure very
many of you have not done--
the zero point X problems,
because they're--
that's going to come
in handy right now.
And so I'll help
you through that.
Remember-- you should remember,
but you may not have looked
at it--
something called
Chomsky normal form,
which is for
context-free grammars,
but only allows the rules
to be of a special kind.
And they have to look like this.
They can be a variable
that goes to two variables,
on the right-hand
side, or a variable
that goes to a terminal.
Those are the only kinds of
rules that you're allowed.
This is a special case
for the empty string,
but let's ignore that for--
the start variable can also
work to the empty string,
if you want to have a-- the
empty string in a language.
But that's a special case.
Let's ignore that.
These are the only
two kinds of rules
that you can have in a
Chomsky normal form grammar.
Once you have a Chomsky
normal form grammar--
well, first of all,
there's two things.
First of all, you
can always convert
any context-free grammar
into Chomsky normal form.
So that's given in the textbook.
You do the obvious thing.
I'm not going to
spend time on it.
And you don't have to know it.
It's just a little bit tedious,
but it's straightforward
and it's there,
if you're curious.
But the second lemma's
the thing that's
important to us, which is that,
if you have a grammar which
is in Chomsky normal form and
a string that's generated,
every derivation of that
string has exactly 2 times
the length of the
string minus 1 steps.
If you think about it, this is
a lemma-- very easy to prove.
I think the homework
problem asks
you to prove that in
the 0.2 or whatever
it was in problem set 1--
or problem set 2--
I don't remember.
Rules of this kind allow you
to make the string one longer,
and rules of this kind allow
you to produce a new terminal
symbol.
If the length w is n, you're
going to have n minus 1
of these and n of.
Those that's why you
get 2n minus 1 steps.
But the point is that I don't
really care exactly how many.
It's just that we have a bound.
And once you have
that bound, life
is good from the point
of view of giving
a Turing machine which is
going to decide this language--
because here's the
Turing machine.
What it's going to do--
the first thing is
it's going to convert G
into Chomsky normal form.
That we assume we
know how to do.
Now, we're going to try all
derivations, but only those
of length 2--
twice the length of
the string minus 1,
because if any derivation
is going to generate w,
it has to be this many steps,
now that we know the grammar
is in Chomsky normal form.
OK, so we have
converted this problem
of one that might be a very
unboundedly lengthy problem
and to one where it's going
to terminate after some fixed
number of steps.
And so therefore, we can
accept, if any of those
generate w, and reject if not.
OK?
Before moving on, so this
answers the problem--
shows that this language is
decidable, the ACFG language.
So that's something that--
make sure you understand.
We're basically trying
old derivations of up to--
of a certain length,
because that's
all that's needed when the
grammar is in that form.
Now we're going to use that
to prove a corollary, which
is important for understanding
how everything fits together.
And that corollary states that
every context-free language
is a decidable language.
Every context-free
language is decidable.
Now, why does that
follow from this?
Well, suppose you have
a context-free language.
We know that
language is generated
by some context-free grammar
G. That's what it means.
So then you can take that
grammar G and you can build it
into a Turing machine.
So there's going to be a term
machine which is constructed
with the knowledge of G.
And that Turing machine
is going to take its w
and run the ACFG algorithm
with w combined with a G that's
already built into it.
So it's just going to stick
that grammar G in front of w,
and now we run the ACFG decider.
It's going to say,
does degenerate w?
Well, that's going to be
yes every time w is in A.
And so this machine here
now is going to end up
accepting every
string that's in A,
because it's every
string that G generates.
So that is, I think, what
I wanted to say about this.
Now, I feel that this
corollary here throws
a little bit of a curveball.
And we can just
pause for a moment
here just to make sure
you're understanding this.
The tricky thing about
this corollary is--
that I often get--
a question I often get where--
is when we start off with
a context-free language,
who gives--
how do we get G?
Because we need G to build
a Turing machine M sub G. So
we know A is a
context-free language,
but how do we know what G is?
Well, the point is that
we may not know what G is,
but we know G exists, because
that's a definition of A
being a context-free language.
It must have a context-free
grammar, by definition.
And so because G exists, I now
know my Turing machine, M sub
G, exists.
And that's enough to
know that A is decidable,
because it has a
decider that exists.
Now, if you're not going to
tell me the grammar for G,
I'm not going to tell you the
Turing machine which decides A.
But both of them exist.
So if you tell me G, then I can
tell you the Turing machine.
So it's a subtle,
tricky issue there.
A certain little element
maybe of-- sometimes people
call it non-constructive,
because we're just, in a sense,
showing just that
something is existing.
It does the job for
us, because it shows
that A is a decidable language.
OK, so not so many questions
here-- maybe the TAs
are getting them.
So let's move on.
Here's another check-in.
So now, can we conclude that A--
instead of ACFG,
APDA is decidable?
People are getting
this one pretty fast.
Another 10 seconds--
three seconds--
OK, going to shut it down--
end polling, share results.
Yeah.
So this problem here
is APDA is decidable.
I was almost wondering whether
or not to give this poll,
because it has-- it's true for
the same reason as poll number
1, because we know
how to convert PDAs--
or we stated we can
convert PDAs to CFGs.
And that conversion
has given in the book.
We didn't do in
lecture, but I just
stated you have
to know that fact,
but not necessarily
know how to do it.
That's OK.
But the fact is true.
The conversion is
in the book, and it
could be implemented
on a Turing machine.
So if you want to know whether
a PDA's language is empty,
you convert it to a context-free
grammar and then use this
procedure here to test
whether it's a language--
oh, not empty-- I'm sorry.
The acceptance problem--
I just want to know, does
the PDA accept some input?
I'm saying it wrong.
So I want to know, does
the PDA accept some input?
I convert that PDA to
a grammar, and then I
see if the grammar generates
that input, because it's
an equivalent grammar.
So again, this is using the
fact that grammars and PDAs are
equivalent and convertible
from one to another,
just like regular
expressions and DFAs
from the previous poll.
So you need to be
comfortable with that,
because we're going to not
even talk about it anymore.
We're just going to be
treating those things--
going back and forth between
them without sometimes
even any comment.
OK.
So let's move on.
Emptiness problem for CFGs--
hopefully you're
getting comfortable
with the terminology I'm using.
So now the emptiness problem
for context-free grammars--
I'm just going to
give you a grammar,
and I want to know if
its language is empty.
OK, so remember, we did
this for finite automata
by testing a path.
We don't really have paths here.
You might think testing
paths and pushed automata.
That's not going to really work,
because the stack is there.
So how are we going
to do that test?
Well, there's something
sort of like testing a path,
just working with
the grammar itself,
kind of working backwards
from the terminals now.
I'll illustrate that here.
Here's a very simple
grammar, and I want to know,
does it generate any strings?
Obviously, only care about
strings of terminals,
because those are the things
that are in the language--
so does this grammar generate
any strings of terminals?
So way we're going to answer
that is by a marking procedure,
but in a sense, we're going
to start from the terminals
and work backwards to see if we
can get to the start variable.
So first, we're going to mark
all the terminal symbols,
and then we're going
to mark anything
that goes to a string of
completely marked symbols,
either terminals or variables--
because anything that's
marked, we know, can derive
a string of terminals.
That's what it means.
Anything that's blue can derive
a string of just terminals.
And so now, if you
have a collection
of those that are all
marked, they together
can generate some string
of terminals together.
And so then you can mark
the associated variable.
So T goes to a.
So that may be
oversimple, but we're
going to mark T here
everywhere in the grammar.
So all these T's are
going to get marked,
because we know that T can
generate a string of terminals.
Now let's take a
look at R. R is going
to a string of symbols
that are all marked,
and that means those symbols
can, in turn, generate
strings of terminals.
So we're going to mark R2.
We can't yet mark S,
because we don't know yet
whether S has some unmarked
thing that it goes to.
So we don't know
yet whether S can
generate a string of terminals.
But R we know right now,
so we're going to mark R.
But then now that gets
us to mark this R,
and so then we can go
backwards and we can mark S.
And we keep doing that until
there's nothing new to mark.
And here we've
marked everything,
so clearly there's
nothing more you can mark.
But you might stop before
you've marked everything.
And then you see whether you've
marked the start variable
or not.
And if you have, you know
the language is not empty.
OK, so let's just go
through this in text.
Mark all occurrences
of terminals in G, then
repeat until no new
variables are marked.
We mark all occurrences
of variables A,
if A goes to a
string of symbols,
and all of those symbols
were already marked,
because those are
the things that
already have been shown to
generate a string of terminals.
And so now we're going to
reject if the start date--
start variable's marked--
because that means that
the language is not empty--
and accept if it's not.
OK?
I'll take a couple of
quick questions here.
OK, somebody asked whether--
if I understand-- are the
regular languages also
decidable?
Well, remember, the
regular languages
are context-free languages,
and the context-free languages
are decidable, so yes,
the regular languages
are decidable.
Some of those are going
to be too long to answer,
and they're trying to come up
with alternative solutions.
So I think we're
going to move on.
All right.
Just like we did for
the finite automata,
we talked about acceptance,
we talked about emptiness,
we talked about equivalence.
So how about the equivalence
problem for context-free
grammars?
I'm going to give you now
two context-free grammars,
and I'd like to know, are
those two context-free grammars
generating the same language?
OK, so how might you
think about that?
Well, one thing-- following some
of the ideas that we've already
had, you could try feeding
strings into those grammars.
You know how to test whether
those individual grammars can
generate those strings,
so you can just
try feeding strings
in to G and to H,
and seeing whether those
grammars ever disagree
or whether they
generate some string.
Find some string that say
G generates, but H does not
generate.
And we can test that
string by string.
Unfortunately, we got a
lot of strings to test.
We would need to give
some bound if we were
going to use that procedure--
not clear what the bound is.
Another idea might be to
use the closure construction
that we had from before.
So let's mull that over--
whether that might work.
But in fact, let me give
away the answer here.
This language is not decidable.
There's no algorithm out
there-- no Turing machine,
but therefore no algorithm--
which can take two grammars
and test whether they generate
the same language or not--
seems, at first, glance
kind of surprising.
Such simple things as
context-free grammars can
nonetheless be so complicated
that there's no procedure out
there which can tell
whether the two--
those two grammars
generate the same language.
We will show that next week.
A related problem, which is
related to your homework--
this that's due on Thursday--
is testing whether a
grammar is ambiguous.
So given a grammar,
I'd like to know,
is that grammar an
ambiguous grammar or not?
Does it generate some
string in the language
of that grammar in two
possibly different ways, two
or more different ways?
So is there some string
that can be generated
with two different parts.
So the problem with testing
whether grammar is ambiguous--
not decidable.
So I'm asking you to
do something hard,
when you have to produce that
grammar which is unambiguous
for that language.
In general, testing
whether a grammar is
ambiguous or is not
a decidable problem.
Now, hopefully the grammar that
you'll produce to show that--
that unambiguous grammar
for that language
that I'm asking you
to produce is not
going to require our graders to
solve some decidable problem,
but it'll be clear based the
construction of that grammar
why it's not ambiguous.
So you'll have to hopefully
say some explanation
of your thinking there.
OK.
And we will prove that the
problem of testing ambiguity
is not decidable.
That's going to be a homework
problem in problem set 3.
OK.
Last check-in here--
something that I alluded
to, but didn't quite--
didn't want to give away.
Why not use the same
technique that we
use to show equivalence
of DFAs is decidable,
to show that equivalence
of context-free grammars
is desirable?
Obviously, something goes wrong
because EQCFG is not decidable.
Why doesn't that same
technique just work?
Well, what's the answer?
Got a real race here--
another 15 seconds-- this
one gives you something
to mull over.
All right.
Let's end it.
OK, you're good to go.
At least click something.
OK, ending polling,
sharing results--
OK, bunch of you have thought,
well, CFGs are generators
and DFAs are recognizers,
and that's the issue.
Well, not really,
because we could test
equivalence of
regular expressions--
those are generators.
It's nothing to do
with being a generator
or not, because we can convert
regular expressions to DFAs
and then test
equivalence for the DFAs,
so that-- it's not really a
matter of being generated.
That's not the issue.
The issue is that we can't
follow the same construction
that we did to show
EQDFA is decidable,
because the context-free
languages are not closed under
those operations we needed to
make that symmetric difference
machine--
if you remember how that worked.
So they're not closed
under implementation
and not closed
under intersection.
We needed both in order
to build that machine
C, which accepted
all the strings that
are in the difference.
OK?
So let's continue on.
Let's move now to
Turing machines.
This is where stuff
is really going
to start to get interesting--
hope it's been interesting
all along, but maybe
even more interesting.
So let's talk about
the acceptance problem
for Turing machines, ATM.
This language is going
to become an old friend,
but we're just
getting to know it.
So this is the problem.
You're given a Turing
machine now, and an input,
and I want to know, does
M accept that input?
Does that Turing machine
accept its input?
OK, so that's going to not be
a decidable problem either.
So we've shifted gears from
a bunch of decidable things
to a bunch of
undecidable things.
So this is not a
decidable language.
We will prove that on Thursday.
That's going to be the whole
point of Thursday's lecture
is proving the ATM is decidable.
And that's going to be
really a jumping off point
for showing other
problems are decidable.
So that's going to be our
first proof of decidability.
But we do know that
ATM is recognizable,
and that's worth understanding--
for multiple reasons,
but for one thing,
it's going to give us an
example of a problem which
we know is recognizable,
but not decidable,
as we'll prove undecidability.
But it's also, I think,
of historical importance,
this algorithm for showing--
recognizable.
So let's go through
that algorithm.
It's very simple, sort of
doing the obvious thing.
The following Turing machine--
I'm going to call it U, for
a reason that I'll make clear
in a second.
That's going to be a
recognizer for ATM.
So it takes as
input an M and a w,
and it's just going to simulate
M on w, pretty much the way
the algorithm the
decider for ADFA work.
But now the machine--
instead of being a DFA,
it's a Turing machine,
and the Turing machine
might go forever.
And so the simulation
may not stop.
And that's the key difference,
which makes it from a decider
into a recognizer.
So you're going to
be simulating, just
keeping track of the tape of M,
the current state of M, where--
and proceeding to modify
the tape as M modifies it.
And then, if M enters
an accept state,
then you know M has
accepted its input,
so U also will enter
an accept state.
So the machine U
enters the accept state
if M observes during
the simulation
that M enters an accept state.
Furthermore, if an M
enters a reject state,
then U also enters
a reject state.
OK?
Now I'm going to say
something beyond that, which
I want you to pay attention to,
which is the kind of thing I
do see sometimes people saying.
We want U to reject
if M never halts.
That's also-- seems
like what we want,
because if it never halts,
then M is rejecting by looping,
so you should also reject.
But I don't like that.
I don't like that line here,
step 4 of the Turing machine,
because there's no way for a
Turing machine to determine--
or at least as we--
no obvious way--
and in fact, there
will not be any way,
but certainly, at this
point, no obvious way for M
to even tell--
for U you to tell whether
M is halting or not.
Well, certainly you
can tell that it's
to say it never halts.
How can you make
that determination?
If I saw this on a
solution, either on an exam
or a homework, I
would mark you off.
This is no good.
It's not illegal to
Turing machine action.
If M does not hold on w,
then you should reject.
That is correct.
And you can make that reasoning
external to the algorithm of U,
but U is going to end up
rejecting, because it never
holds either.
It never actually knows that
M is rejecting w in that case,
if M is rejecting by looping.
It's just blindly going along
and doing the simulation of M
on w--
and will end up halting--
rejecting by looping, if
M is rejecting by looping.
But that's something
that you can
argue if you need
to make a proof
or make some sort of
reasoning about the machine,
but it's not part of the
algorithm of the machine.
OK.
Now, what's, I think, from
a historical standpoint,
that's interesting
about this machine U
and why I'm calling it U
is because this appeared--
this machine U appeared
in Turing's original paper
where he laid out
Turing machines.
He didn't call them Turing
machines, by the way.
He called them
computing machines.
People afterward called
them Turing machines.
But Turing called this the
universal computing machine.
That's his language.
Actually, I just
looked at the paper
yesterday just to
refresh my memory of it.
And he gives the description
of the operation of U
in gory detail, with all of
the transitions and the states.
He nails the whole
thing down-- takes
pages, and pages, and pages.
So he it gives it there.
So this is the original
universal computing machine,
universal Turing machine.
It's more than just
an idle curiosity
that this appeared
in Turing's paper,
because this actually
turned out to be profoundly
influential in computer
science, because it really
was the first example of
a machine that operated
based on a stored program.
It really was a
revolutionary idea.
In those days, if
you wanted to make
a machine that did
something different,
you had to wire the--
rewire the machine.
But here's a machine that
operated based on instructions.
And instructions, in a sense,
are no different than the data.
So this is what's been--
come to be known as the
von Neumann architecture,
but von Neumann himself gave
credit to Turing machine
for having inspired
him to think of this.
And some people argue
that it's really--
calling it the von Neumann--
bunch of people came
up with this concept
around the same time,
maybe other people too.
There's Babbage and so
on, and others who--
Ada Lovelace-- also who came
up with notions of programming,
but I think it's a little
different than this,
in concept.
But anyway, this nevertheless
played an important role
in the history of the subject.
So with that, I think
we're out of time.
I'm going to quickly
review where we've been.
So we just showed
the decidability
of various problems.
These are all languages that
we showed are decidable.
We showed that ATM is
Turing-recognizable,
and I think that was
all we had for today.
So I will stop right here.
I will stick around and
take a few questions,
and our TAs can take a few
questions, if you want,
by chat.
And then I also have
my office hours,
which will start in
like five minutes or so,
once I get everything
set up on my end.
OK, somebody wanted me to
review this point here,
which I'm happy to do.
This code here that I'm
describing in English
needs to be something
that you can
implement on a Turing machine.
We're never going to go
through the effort of building
the transition functions,
and the states, and so on,
but we need to be sure that
we could, if we had to.
And how could you make a
Turing machine do the test
that M doesn't halt?
That's something we
don't know how to do.
I can see if M halts.
During the simulation,
I can see that M
has entered the Q reject
state or the Q accept state,
so I can tell while I'm
simulating that it has halted.
But how would the
machine, or how
would you know that M is now--
someone says, well,
do x if M never holds.
Well, how do you know M--
how can you do the test
that M is not halting?
There's no obvious
way to do that.
In fact, there is
no way to do that.
But as it stands
right now, the proof
would be on you to show how to
implement that on a machine,
and there's just no
obvious way to do that.
So I think that's why you
should only put down things
here which you're sure
you could implement,
even if it might
take a long time.
So you don't have to worry
about how long it would take,
but you have to put
things down that you
are sure you could at least
implement in principle.
OK, so someone has asked me
about the equivalence problem
for context-free grammars
being unsolvable.
Why couldn't the machine be
a human level system of logic
so that the computer could
logically deduce whether or not
it was decidable?
We're taking a turn
into the subject
of mathematical logic, which is
supposed to formalize reasoning
in a way.
In the end, what it
really has come down to--
that there are
certain grammars which
are equivalent to one
another, but there's not
going to be any way
to prove that they're
equivalent in any
reasonable system.
Inequivalence you
can always prove.
You can exhibit a
string that one-- you
can show that this
grammar's generating it,
this grammar's not generating.
This other one is not.
So inequivalence you can
always prove, but equivalence--
there are going to be certain
pairs of grammars which
are going to be
beyond the capability
of any reasonable
formal system to be
able to prove that
they're equivalent,
because you can even convert--
make those grammars
into something
which talk about the
system itself, ultimately.
You're going to end up with a
Russell paradox kind of thing.
That's maybe going beyond
more than you want to know,
and I'm happy to talk
about it offline.
But there's just no way to make
a Turing machine which is going
to implement human reasoning,
and then get the right answer
on all pairs of grammars--
just cannot be done.
Goodbye.
I'm going to shut
down the meeting now.